in this problem a circular clarifier has
a diameter of 30 ft and a depth of 10 ft
it receives about 2.5 million gallons
per day of flow how long is the
detention time of each cycle of flow in
hours assuming all Cycles reside in the
clarifier for the same amount of
time so the first thing to note in this
problem is that this problem is not
really about clarifiers so don't waste
your time time looking over the 22
references to clarifiers that appear in
the manual this is actually just a basic
geometry problem disguised as a topic
about clarifiers that is very easy to
solve so let's go through
it the problem gives us the dimensions
of the clarifier and the total amount of
flow that passes through it per day it
also asks us how long the flow remains
in the
clarifier so all we need to do is find
the volume of the clarifier
and figure out how many times the
clarifier needs to cycle flow through it
to get through all of the 2.5 million
gallons per day first based on the
dimensions provided this clarifier is
actually a cylinder page 10 of the
manual gives us the geometry of a
cylinder we can see we have a diameter
of 30
ft and a depth of 10
ft using the equation for a cylinder on
on page 10 of the manual we get V = pi
d^2 over
4 *
H so we can fill that in as Pi
* 30 ft^
squared over
4 * 10
ft and this should give us just about
7,065 cubic
feet next the flow in MGD should be
converted to
CFS so
2.5
MGD
equals
2.5 * 10
gallons per
day and using page three of the
reference manual for our unit conversion
we can see that 1 cubic
foot equal
7.48
gallons and this conversion will get us
to 3 3 4
5 cubic feet gallons cancel
out and day remains on the
bottom now that our units are constant
we can see how many times the tank needs
to cycle flow in order to pass all
334,000 is cubic feet through it per
day so step three we've got 3 3 4
225 fet cubed
per day divided
by
765 ft
cubed and this gives us just about
47.3
cycles per
day finally we have step four
if each Cycle's detention time is the
same then all we need to do is find
out how long each cycle is per
day
so 24
hours per
day
times one day over
47.3 Cycles
gives
us just about
0.5
hours per
cycle so you can see how we kept our
units through this whole
problem and came up with the final
answer here so again this is an easy
problem if you don't get tricked into
thinking that it's actually using
equations or Val vales specific to
clarifiers all we need to do is some
unit conversion and division the volume
equation of a cylinder and the unit
conversion from MGD to cubic feet per
day are given in the manual and that's
it